I think these things are hard to do and
hard to be prescriptive about and there
are reasons that we are not France and
the two reasons are we are more feminist
than France and we are more puritanical
than France those are the two popular
reasons and yes I think we should be
more like the French in this respect I
think we should have been more like the
French before the Iraq war two but in in
with respect to you know the women in
France I think have a little bit of a
hard time I've been told the wives have
to put up with a lot because it's the
men who typically have a mistress and I
don't think that's easy but I think that
one thing that we could emulate about
the French is that the marriage is not
quite so burdened with the sort of
romantic and sort of passionate
responsibility down you know over 20
years there's a little bit more it's a
more of a formal institution and I think
that if people here came to see marriage
is a little bit more of a formal
institution they wouldn't divorce at the
drop of a hat and they would try to see
that the marriage has great rewards
financially in terms of raising children
as a you know career wise i think
marriage for me my marriage I mean again
I you know I have a sexy marriage but my
career is I'll be I'd be helpless in my
career without my wife and that's
something that I would just you know
freak if I lost my marriage
you